hey guys how's it going I'm Justine and
we're back in my kitchen today we're
gonna be making something very festive
for the holidays now I live in Los
Angeles but we don't really get snow so
any bit of kind of snow or cold weather
type items that we can find we really
get excited about it and today I'm going
to be making a melted snowman chocolates
white chocolate bark thing it looks like
this I'm excited about this because I'm
a huge white chocolate fan I love white
chocolate I basically will buy white
chocolate chips even directly out of the
bags so for our melted snowman we're
going to need a few items we need white
chocolate little recieves
mini cups M&Ms orange starbursts and
some little pretzel sticks
I got gluten-free kids too because the
first thing that we're gonna do is we're
gonna dump our chocolate chips into a
bowl and we're going to microwave them
and melt them
I need to make sure that they taste okay
because oh yeah they taste great so
we're going to microwave these it says
to stir them every 30 to 45 seconds
until smooth
all right melt it up
it's been 30 seconds let's take a peek
we've got some melting happening cool
so our chocolate is almost ready I'm
going to put down some parchment paper
to put the hot chocolate on you have to
work fast
before the chocolate sets up oh gosh
all right nervous probably take this out
now I think yeah this is Jesus it's
really hot hot just like an oven my gosh
they told me you have to work fast I'm
looking I'm not ready I don't have any
of my items prepared I've got to cut the
starbursts I've got to get the M&M I
feel like let's just dump this see what
happens
okay this is so hot I'm burning myself
everything looks so much better like on
the internet like everything just looks
great
this look like a melted little snowman
to you yes sure dad
okay I said we have to work fast so we
do not have much time time is not on our
side all they suddenly chocolate chips
too for the eyes all right how is there
only one green M&M in this whole pack I
you kidding me
this is ludicrous holiday is red and
green what kind of world are you living
in what world is this
Trump is president and there's only one
great habitat this is an i and I hmm
house is going green M&M Merry Christmas
all right we gotta have another green
M&M yeah there's got to be yes yes look
at this that's where they all work
have a holly jolly Christmas best time
of the year
that's great down here all the food and
friends and family fun gonna cut in half
this little guy you're not really sure
like I guess you just stick it wherever
you want to stick it that's what she's
she's she's diving I said it we need our
little pretzels this is his little arm
it's a very sad sad sight honestly I do
remember when I was little and we would
go outside and our snowmen would be
melted it's pretty depressing sight test
and an orange ones right on top thank
you
I almost sliced my finger I almost
pierced it this is supposed to be the
snowman's nose I was going to use real
carrots but then I thought I can do a
little
cut here yes here we don't know that's
handsome that's nice so here we have our
little melted snowman and now we'll let
this school I will see what happens
later I guess I could probably make one
more right there but I'm not we let our
snowmen cool for a really long time
actually so now I'm going to cut them
and see what happens
oh it's cutting look nice
let's go good yay so just for a nice
little slice here I think I might have
some things happened here I think I
forgot to put a pretzel somewhere
because this is not right yeah they look
good
let me get a plate so he might have had
a problem but that's ok we can't all be
perfect like this one these are so cute
oh my goodness I think this might be my
most successful thing I've ever made a
lot I love it I'm definitely having a
Christmas party now and this will be my
dessert and here we are our final
products our little melted snowmen thank
you guys so much for watching
merry christmas happy holidays and let
me know if you guys decide to recreate
to this delicious masterpiece be sure to
send me a photo you can send to me on
Twitter I just seen Instagram I just
seen snapchat I just seen Facebook I
just seen you get the point okay that's
it bye I'm gonna go eat these now I'll
Bachchan wife Paige
mmm look hello kitty got him get a
little cake one interest cuz everybody's
like book with me I'm over here like
look at me everything is in failure but
don't let that discourage you success
comes in many packages so I'm just
looking